that's no moon it's a space station the
enormous planet killing kind designed
for only one thing to bring order to the
galaxy it's Star Wars Imperial super
weapon the Death Star what would it take
to build a star like this where would we
assemble the universe's biggest weapon
of mass destruction and what unfortunate
planet would be the first target for our
test firing this is what if and here's
what would happen if we could build the
Death Star I've got a bad feeling about
this but it took the Empire 19 years to
build their first Death Star so we
better get started it's unclear exactly
how big the ds1 orbital battle station
was estimates vary between 120
kilometers and 160 kilometers in
diameter that's substantially smaller
than say our Moon but compared to some
of the smallest moons in the solar
system its enormous and we'd only need
one thing to build it money lots of
money big projects cost big money in
this case we're talking eight hundred
and fifty two quadrillion dollars eight
hundred and fifty two with fifteen zeros
and that's only the cost of construction
once the Death Star is ready keeping it
up and running wouldn't be any cheaper
weapon or not this space station would
require 1.7 million staff to run the
station's retail shops and troop
cafeterias add twenty-five thousand nine
hundred and eighty four stormtroopers
and three hundred and forty two thousand
nine hundred and fifty three Imperial
Navy soldiers and you'll get two million
sixty eight thousand nine hundred and
thirty-seven people living aboard the
Death Star if each person on the Death
Star created one point
three kilograms of waste every day it
would cost five hundred and sixty four
thousand nine hundred and twenty-five
dollars daily not to turn the death star
into a landfill
that doesn't include people who fell
into a trash compactor and weren't able
to blast their way out the daily
electricity bill would add up to fifty
two billion dollars two hundred and
seventy four thousand dollars to feed
the crew with another twenty thousand
four hundred dollars to supply tear
coffee two hundred and thirty three
thousand for one cycle of laundry you
wouldn't expect your troopers to run
around with dirty underwear right the
total for keeping the death star
operational would amount to 7.8
octillion dollars every day that's more
money than we currently have here on
earth and it doesn't include the cost of
a single blast of super laser that would
be an additional eight octillion dollars
still feel like firing lasers into
planets okay then let's talk about how
you could build the Death Star you
already know it would come with the
price tag of eight hundred and fifty two
quadrillion dollars but where would you
start assembling this super weapon first
you'd need a HyperMatter reactor core
let's not go into the specifics of how
such a reactor would work and we'll just
assume that you already have one you'd
build four reactor shafts all joined
along the equator and a large column
running from top to bottom this column
would help to distribute power and also
act as a station stabilizer
this mega project would require a lot of
Steel by some calculations the earth has
enough iron in its court to provide for
2 million Death Star's but you wouldn't
want to sacrifice our planet for an army
of deadly weapons would you even if you
took only the amount of iron needed for
one Death Star it would take over eight
hundred and thirty thousand years to
produce enough steel so you could begin
construction and it would take millions
of rocket launches to get the steel
where it needed to go by the time the
Death Star was finished this might make
our atmosphere so polluted that we'd be
forced to move away from Earth to
another planet and where would we build
the Death Star anyway we can't get too
far from our planet but you definitely
don't want that thing in Earth's low
orbit there's too much of a chance of it
falling down to earth you could start
building outside of the Earth's
atmosphere just make sure to not
accidentally blast our planet with the
super laser speaking of the blast well
in reality light doesn't behave that way
instead they would keep moving in
whatever direction it was fired by the
way destroying an earth-sized planet
would require a lot of power you'd need
to spend a week collecting all of the
sun's energy before you could fire up
the Death Star and don't stand anywhere
close to the beam at the moment of the
blast so much energy right next to you
even when not aimed directly at you
would cause you to evaporate in a matter
of seconds then there's the recoil the
third law of motion teaches us that
every action has an equal and opposite
reaction that means if you packed a big
enough punch to destroy a planet using
the sun's energy it would send the Death
Star in the opposite direction at a
speed of 77 km/h
that's unless you had an antimatter
device aboard the Death Star antimatter
is matter but with its electrical charge
reversed when antimatter meets matter
the to destroy one another that's why
you'd need only zero point zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero two percent of
a targeted planets mass in antimatter to
turn that planet into space debris in
this case the recoil would be almost
unnoticeable but you'd better not aim
that Death Star at any planets in the
solar system there's a better
application for this weapon it could be
used to vaporize any asteroids that
could be a risk for our planet although
a giant Death orb might be a little
overqualified for the task at least when
an interstellar asteroid is hurdling in
our direction we'd be ready to knock it
out before it destroys us I've got a bad
feeling about me
building the Deathstar would be a very
long and very expensive process do or do
not there is no try
but maybe spare the earth for now and
save the deadliest weapon in the galaxy
for some angry aliens that might come to
visit us one day but that's a story for
another what if
[Music]